Trauma is something that's unexpected
out of our control and outside of our
ability to prevent it.
And so that really by definition is a
loss.
You can have the loss of life,
the loss of physical control,
which is an injury,
the loss of emotional control,
which is a mental health need.
You can have a financial loss.
So loss of that nature brings trauma
and mass casualty can take the form of a
violent crime or an individual's
involved in harming lots of other
people.
It can be a natural disaster.
It can be a combination of those things.
Many times in the public,
people don't know how to respond and so
they kind of default to what they would
perceive to be something that's helpful.
So donating clothes,
knitting things,
sending food,
this kind of thing.
And ironically,
in many situations that's not really
that helpful.
Somebody drove a truck,
a tractor trailer full of fruitcake and
actually parked it in the middle of the
disaster zone.
You know,
one,
forget it would be funny actually,
but you know,
in in the midst of this natural
disaster,
it's not the right kind of resources
that to big people typically need.
They need other kinds of resources and
those needs,
uh,
commonly revolve around immediate safety
and security issues.
Uh,
immediate,
immediate emotional support and then
time to recover to some degree.
What do you typically get when you say,
well,
is there anything I can do for you?
Well,
there's nothing.
You know,
I'm,
I'm fine when at that casket,
when you make that comment to that widow
at her,
you know,
her husband's visitation,
she's not thinking,
yeah,
the grass hasn't been mowed and my
mortgage needs to be paid and the dog
needs to be let out.
All very practical things.
And many times that's really what we
need to focus on.
How do we discover those practical needs
by asking them
in the aftermath of a situation,
people are recovering emotionally,
physically,
financially,
and many times those needs are lifelong.
If a person loses his or her job and
can't work,
that's an issue of disability.
That's a need.
Paying funeral expenses,
dealing with medical expenses,
medical bills,
sometimes they're still trying to make
their house payment.
Do they have resources to be able to
manage with that?
Do they have the ability to get worker's
comp or longterm disability that can be
questionable?
A manager of a compensation program is
State Compensation Program told me that
they consider the average cost of a
shooting victim who survived to be
roughly $50,000 that's,
that's the calculable consideration for
their costs,
their expenses,
and so even just financially,
you know,
that's,
that's where donations can be helpful
and so it's important for the public to
be thoughtful,
to make sure that whatever account that
you might be contributing to is actually
the legitimate take an extra step or to
ask some questions to do a google search
and to make sure it's legitimate and
authentic.
When you think about how we respond to a
person,
we challenge people to ask the question,
am I really defining their trauma for
them by the statement that I'm making?
For instance,
God wanted your loved one more than you
did.
That's why he took your loved one.
Well,
when you kind of examine that phrase,
what are we really doing?
We're defining that loss for that
individual.
Most people who are experiencing that
kind of loss would say,
that's not helpful.
I don't find actually that that is
comforting to me.
Comforting phrases,
truly comforting phrases are really the
kind of phrases that empower the person
to have control.
One of the big phrases that we use
really in terms of crisis intervention
is,
I'm so sorry that your loved one died
and use that person's name.
I'm so sorry that bill died because
we're,
we're affirming the value of that person
that they've lost and we're affirming
the reality of what they've experienced.
Now,
the easiest thing,
believe it or not,
is to say nothing,
and that can be helpful just to be with
a person.
If we don't know what to say,
you can simply say,
I'm here with you.
I just want to support you.